on en parlait en début d'émission
l'unité locale de la Croix-Rouge de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines étant manque
de bénévoles des épiceries solidaires
risquent la fermeture pour en parler
avec nous le président de la Croix-Rouge
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Denis
largeot et le vice-président Claude qui
nous a rejoint en plateau bonsoir alors
comment est-ce que vous expliquez
aujourd'hui ce manque de bénévoles
qui sont consécutifs en premier lieu au
covid
dans la période du covid on a eu
beaucoup de défections parce que nos
bénévoles sont des gens relativement
âgés ce sont des gens qui sont
principalement à la retraite puisque nos
bénévoles travaillent la semaine donc le
covid nous a
contraint à contraint un certain nombre
de personnes de ne plus accéder à aux
épiceries donc ça c'est la première
raison la deuxième raison c'est que les
choses changent et que le bénévolat
maintenant c'est plus tout comme avant
avant on était on s’engagé et on
s'engageait sur le long terme maintenant
on fait du bénévolat court terme
c'est une fois une fois par semaine une
fois la semaine et puis trois semaines
ou 4 semaines après donc il y a pas de
continuité or nos épiceries et elles
sont ouvertes toute la semaine donc nous
avons besoin de continuité
donc c'est ça la raison la dernière
raison je crois que personne n'a
intuitité cette raison là mais les
problèmes économiques que nous avons
font que beaucoup de grands-parents et
Ben sont contraint de s'occuper de leur
petit enfant parce que les couples n'ont
plus les moyens de avoir une nounou
d'avoir
un certain nombre de choses donc
beaucoup de grands-parents qui étaient
nos bénévoles et bien ne viennent plus
parce que il faut s'occuper des petits
enfants
et alors ne viennent plus ou ne viennent
plus pendant certaines périodes pour
être précis par exemple
alors comment fait-on aujourd'hui pour
devenir bénévole à la Croix-Rouge et
bien on nous avons aussi un site web sur
lequel on peut trouver l'adresse de la
de la Croix-Rouge de 51 en Yvelines et
ensuite on nous appelle et nous avons
une personne chargée du recrutement le
site web qui s'affiche juste en bas de
votre écran et donc il y a une personne
qui est dédiée donc recrutement et on
passe un entretien entre guillemets
c'est une prise de contact et après les
les bénévoles peuvent intégrer l'unité
locale pour travailler alors quels sont
justement les différentes missions les
différentes tâches qu'on peut effectuer
si on devient d'être 50 ans est une des
plus grandes unités locales des Yvelines
c'est même la plus grande
donc nous avons une halte répit
Alzheimer nous avons un espace bébé
parents nous avons la maraude Claude en
est la responsable nous avons les
secouristes on est la plus grosse unité
locale avec 50 pas tout à fait 45
secondes nous avons deux épiceries et la
vestibouti la vestiboutique nous avons
une domiciliation la domiciliation à
l'heure actuelle nous avons environ 500
personnes domiciliées chez nous ça veut
dire 500 personnes c'est 500 courriers
ce que c'est la domiciliation c'est pour
les personnes qui n'ont pas de logement
fixe c'est donner une adresse aux
personnes qui n'ont pas de logement fixe
comme vous dites et donc c'est recevoir
le courrier trier le courrier donner le
courrier ça demande
un nombre de bénévoles importants à
l'heure actuelle nous n'en n'avons pas
assez donc nous ouvrons que le mardi
après-midi
pour distribuer le courrier parce que on
reçoit entre 50 et 100 personnes et donc
il faut des bras pour ça
vous constatez une baisse des personnes
qui souhaitent s'engager dans le
bénévolat ou du bénévolat par
intermittence si on peut utiliser ce
terme du phénomène que vous avez décrit
vous personnellement je vous pose la
question à tous les deux qu'est-ce qui
vous motive encore à vous engager dans
le bénévolat alors vous êtes Président
vous êtes vice-président mais qu'est-ce
qui motive en général les personnes qui
sont à la Croix-Rouge qu'est-ce qu'il
est motivé à s'engager dans le bénévolat
c'est comme Claude ou moi nous sommes
engagés pour aider les gens
on ne sait pas engager pour être
vice-président ou Président on s'est
engagé pour aider les gens vous savez
dans les épiceries nous avons plus de
1000 familles dans les deux épiceries
mille familles si on n'est pas là ces
gens-là ne mangent pas
d'accord et on me dit si tu as pas assez
de bénévoles tu fermes oui mais que
deviennent les gens que deviennent les
gens qui frappent à la porte de
l'épicerie tous les jours donc si on
tire une conclusion de ce que vous dites
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne
souhaitent pas aider les gens puisqu'ils
sont pas motivés à aider les autres je
pense pas je dirais pas ça pour être en
dehors de la polémique non je dirais que
le bénévolat change que les contraintes
sont différentes que le covid nous a
donné un coup de frein énorme et que la
situation économique fait que les
grands-parents qui sont le nerf de la
guerre des bénévoles dans notre unité
locale les grands-parents s'occupent
d'autres choses ben écoute déjà alors du
scandale est-ce que vous tournez vers le
public de jeunes qui pourraient
s'engager dans la sauce on se tourne
vers les jeunes pour le secouriste le
secouristes nous avons une unité
secouriste qui est la plus grande des
Yvelines et ça ce sont des jeunes des
jeunes du travail la semaine mais qui le
week-end et ben font du bénévolat dans
les secouristes et ça marche très bien
par contre pour la semaine ces jeunes là
ils sont pas disponibles alors on
utilise beaucoup de stagiaires donc ce
sont des étudiants maintenant je sais
pas si vous le savez mais dans une
universités donc cursus il y a un cursus
demandé de solidarité donc on a beaucoup
d'étudiants qui viennent faire ces
stages chez nous mais le reste des
bénévoles ce sont des gens qui sont à la
retraite et alors Nicolas dandry vous
avez demandé pourquoi Denis largeot et
Claude gwenacheteur était bénévole
souhaité s'engager nous sommes aussi
allés demander aux bénévoles de la
Croix-Rouge pourquoi est-ce qu'il
s'était engagé en écoute en fait moi ce
que je veux c'est aider les gens un
maximum c'est ça qui m'a fait venir à la
Croix-Rouge et la Croix-Rouge en fait
font partie de ma vie en fait
quotidienne parce que la Croix Rouge à
17 principes qui sont aussi mes valeurs
ça fait mal au cœur de voir des gens
quelquefois âgés qui sont dehors ou des
tout jeunes ou des femmes enceintes avec
des enfants franchement c'est ça devrait
pas exister mais c'est important qu'il y
ait des gens pour témoigner et puis pour
leur donner un petit peu d'espoir il y a
pas besoin d'avoir un diplôme spécifique
c'est simplement une envie de vouloir
aider les autres
ça c'est très important et venez nous
rencontrer c'est la première chose qu'on
pourrait dire c'est vrai que s'il y
avait plus de monde ça permettrait quand
même un roulement et puis l'espoir que
que les choses avancent alors on
l'entend dans ce micro-trottoir la
Croix-Rouge à cette principe est-ce que
vous pouvez peut-être nous les rappeler
c'est d'abord l'humanité
c'est d'abord
ne pas faire de différence entre les
personnes
être ouvert à tout le monde nous n'avons
pas de restriction que ce soit de
religion ou d'apparence et voilà enfin
c'est les principes c'est surtout
l'humanité et aider les autres c'est ça
qui nous motive tous les jours
de Monsieur du Nord créateur tu peux
lire
alors s'il arrive à lire
unité universalité
neutralité et indépendante
et bien merci beaucoup à vous deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et donc
si vous souhaitez devenir bénévole vous
trouverez toutes les informations
nécessaires sur le site internet qui
s'affiche une nouvelle fois en bas de
votre écran